Hitomi mokazuki is a lifestyle YouTuber
who's gained popularity for her vegan
meal inspo travel Vlogs Wellness
routines clothing hauls short films
poetry and real talks about sexuality
spirituality and mental health but like
most influencers in the wellness space
Hitomi has recently jumped on the gut
hell bandwagon frequently sharing the
diet tips that she's used to allegedly
cleanse and reset her gut buckle up
fellow nutrition nerds we have a lot to
unpack hey everyone I'm Abby sharp
welcome to Abby's kitchen
[Music]
thank you
in today's video we'll be taking a look
at Hitomi mokizuki's cleansing diet to
reset her gut and of course you can
pause the screen or look at my
description to check out my disclaimer
including a trigger warning because we
will be discussing pretty restrictive
diets here so feel free to skip this
video if it's not supportive to your
journey and if you are not already
subscribed hit that subscribe button and
also follow me on Tick Tock and
Instagram at Abby's kitchen alright
lovelies let's get into it this isn't
the kind of cleanse where I restrict my
food I'm trying to lose weight I only
drink liquids and then I have a complete
spiral at the end of it and just eat
tons of the food that I wasn't supposed
to be eating there are a few
contradictions here I mean I am relieved
that the intention of the cleanse is not
weight loss because it would probably be
the worst way to try to lose weight I
mean any weight lost in a few days after
consuming juice or eliminating whatever
Foods would be be immediately regained
once off the cleanse but friends let s
be honest with ourselves a cleanse is a
diet with a more Elite sexy name and
diets by definition require restriction
of some sort there is no scenario where
a healthy body with functioning organs
would need any kind of reset or detox
like your body just does this every
single day constantly when you pee poo
sweat and breathe and any cleanse
specifically for gut health makes zero
sense in my books like gut health is a
long game like the microbiome can change
within just a few days depending on diet
and environmental factors so any
potential benefits will be immediately
erased if you just go back to business
as usual after the alleged cleanse so
yeah that's a pass for me so one is a
yeast cleanse and the other is a
parasite cleanse and I just want to put
good things into my gut so this yeast
cleanse is a simple protocol all using
this ReNew Life Candy smart cleansing
program I'm sure there are other yeast
cleanses that you can do but it's just a
pill and tincture every single day okay
so this cleanse in particular is
allegedly for helping to treat candida
which is a yeast like fungus that can
cause thrush honestly candida has become
grossly over diagnosed in the Wellness
Community like most people who insist
they have candida overgrowth do not meet
the diagnostic criteria at all anyway I
brought this particular product to my
functional Rd and IBS practice groups
and we all agreed that there is no
evidence for a product like this and it
can actually potentially be dangerous
there's a long list of powerful
antimicrobials here like berberine
garlic neem oregano Etc and when taken
together a product like this could
easily wipe out all of your good gut
bacteria not worth the game Bible in my
opinion so if you suspect that you might
have candida overgrowth please speak to
your health care provider because a
basic anti-fungal medication can be
extremely effective and relief is
typically quite quick my kind of
guidelines for doing this cleanse is not
having any processed foods and
especially processed sugars so going
sugar-free is a common approach to
eliminating candida because it's
believed that the sugar kind of feeds
the yeast and the idea is that removing
sugar from the diet will starve the
yeast and therefore effectively kill it
off however most of our evidence on this
theory is based on Research in a test
tube environment not actual humans and
the research that we do have mostly is
found that limiting processed sugar had
very little if any influence on candida
colonization what we do know is that
probiotics may be more effective at
warding off Candida by helping to
populate the gut with healthy bacteria
and as we also know not all probiotics
are created equal so the best probiotic
strains for candida seem to be
lactobacillus paracasi acidophilus
ramnosis and rooteri so as always I do
prefer to focus on what we can add to
the diet to support a healthy gut rather
than always thinking about what we need
to cut out a healthy gut needs diversity
plate this all together with some quinoa
the mushrooms and the veggie burgers and
then a huge dollop of sauerkraut which
is my favorite okay I break down the
evidence on lion's mane mushrooms in my
Tick Tock superfoods video right here
but in short we do have some early
evidence showing that it may help to
protect against Alzheimer's disease
relief symptoms of anxiety and
depression and may even help to boost
cognitive function however most of the
research to date has been done on rats
so we really do need more evidence on
humans to understand how this is going
to apply to us but when it comes to gut
health specifically there is some
research suggesting that lion's mane May
stimulate intestinal immune activity but
again this research has been done on
animals so we don't really have a clear
understanding of its benefits for human
gut health all that said a gut healthy
diet is a diet rich in Pre and
probiotics and this definitely hits all
the marks we have tons of fiber AKA
prebiotics from the quinoa and kale plus
some natural probiotics from the
fermented sauerkraut which also boasts a
variety of supportive digestive enzymes
and I also really love that we've got
healthy fats from the tahini dressing
and protein from the quinoa and veggie
burger so all around this looks like a
delicious hunger crushing and pretty
happy get meal but I added spinach on
top and made it more so into a scramble
I added some sprouted hummus and some
sauerkraut with it as well as some hot
sauce and it is so good I love this
stuff vegan culinary creativity just
never ceases to amaze me because I would
have never thought to integrate soaked
mung beans into a breakfast scramble so
yeah your girl is intrigued but it
definitely does make sense for the gut
since soaking sprouted beans helps to
reduce their anti-nutrient content
making them easier to digest and making
their nutrients more bioavailable as for
the meal itself we're getting protein
from the mung bean and nooch mixture
fiber from the veggies plus some fat in
the hummus this meal is also loaded with
key vegan nutrients like vitamin B12
from the nutritional yeast and iron and
calcium from the mung beans and spinach
and because we've paired the non-heem
iron with vitamin C from the peppers
we're going to dramatically amplify that
irons bioavailability love it I am
really craving sugar right now it's like
my Daydream I've been saving recipes on
Instagram and Pinterest and of different
vegan cookies and brownies and treats
and I'm really feeling some withdrawals
I am also not demonizing any of my
Cravings or every time I go to the
grocery store I let myself know it's
okay if you do eat that vegan
gluten-free cupcake sitting by the
register like everything is available to
you but is it going to make your body
feel good I am choosing out of love not
to rather than restriction or punishing
myself I am confused what how in the
same monologue did we establish that
everything is available to you it's okay
to eat the vegan gluten-free cupcake but
then also I'm craving sugar to the point
of distraction in my day but I won't eat
it because it's not an option for me
like you can have it but no you can't
have it listen I get the dye culture or
it's sexier cousin Wellness culture is
sneaky and I'm not surprised that after
telling herself that she can't have
sugar on this cleanse that she
obsessively wanted it even and more even
though in the past she never felt
attached to Sugar this is what diet
restrictions make us do they make us
want these Foods even more and cause
these deep desires because we are in
scarcity mentality but when we let go of
the bogus cleanses or Diet rules over
time we often can find that our interest
or desire in like less nutritious Foods
may start to dissipate we can make
choices out of love rather than out of
restriction because the option is there
it isn't breaking the cleanse rule even
if she physically feels great on this
cleanse mentally she's using up a lot of
emotional energy daydreaming about vegan
cupcakes that she can't have so I can
appreciate hitomi's desire to nourish
herself with nutrient-rich Foods we need
to find a balance where both physical
and emotional nourishment have a seat at
the table nutrition should never be 1
hundred percent black and white use
whatever you have on hand and I also
cooked some rice which is so yummy with
tomato paste and half an onion chopped
into there while boiling but I just made
Simple Kind rice and this is what it
looks like coming together beans rice
corn Peppers can't really go wrong I got
the mushrooms on there and then I added
even more rice because I was hungry and
I made this fresh guac with red onion
tomato and all the guac things and then
put a huge dollop of sauerkraut right in
the middle this looks insanely delicious
and another excellent example of a
balanced vegan recipe that checks off
all the boxes so we're getting protein
and fiber from the black beans more
fiber from the veggies and corn and
healthy fats from the guac I also
noticed that we've had sauerkraut in
basically every meal here and if that
feels good to her amazing but it's worth
noting that sauerkraut is a AI FODMAP
food so if you're prone to bloating and
gas go slow and gauge how small or
moderate portions make you feel this one
day my friend who works at a donut shop
gave me free donuts and I did not eat
them they are vegan and I gave them away
and I'm really proud of my willpower
there there was a donut eating contest
these Donuts came back to haunt me and I
had one I was like you know what this is
a lifestyle change and having a vegan
donut is okay every now and then I just
I just needed to do it and it was
delicious and I didn't feel horrible
after like in my body I didn't have a
sugar crash but that was my one slip up
yes having a donut is very much okay I
fully understand that for some folks
with complicated histories with food or
specific medical conditions abstinence
or restriction seems like the only way
to manage sugar consumption and it may
be you know everyone's journey is going
to be unique but one of the biggest
predictors of a binge is restriction so
in my experience the most successful way
to manage sugar Cravings is to have some
sugar speckled regularly and
consistently throughout your diet
letting desire Mount by eating around
the craving on what I call the
satisfaction hunt
[Music]
generally results in you over consuming
a bunch of unsatisfying foods until you
finally say it and eat all the
donuts inside I say it's better to just
acknowledge you're craving a donut ask
yourself honestly like is an apple gonna
cut it as a replacement and if not eat
the damn donut judgment free a donut
will not make or break your health and
wellness goals it doesn't make you good
it doesn't make you bad a donut is just
a donut and we finally take it off its
pedestal we can neutralize the power
that that donut has over us and I get
the impression that Hitomi is trying to
Edge herself into this neutral place by
saying all foods are welcome and
insisting that it's not about
restriction or demonizing foods but if
that truly were the case Hitomi would
have just been able to enjoy that donut
like it was no biggie and then carry on
with the rest of her day but instead she
shared her
eternal battle using pretty demonizing
Language by calling the experience a
slip up saying that the donuts were
haunting her and that she had to
exercise willpower not eat them the
first time that is not giving yourself
unconditional permission to eat out of
self-love and I get the hitomi's
approach is to eat foods that make her
feel good and perhaps Donuts don't make
her feel physically great which is why
she tries to avoid them and that is
totally valid and fair but I also think
that developing a healthy relationship
with food is also about collecting data
on how foods make you feel and the fact
that she said that this donut was
delicious and didn't make her feel
horrible in her body I mean I think
tells us that a donut can and absolutely
should be enjoyed without the side of
fear or impending guilt meal that I made
regularly is this kitchery and I also
love air frying tofu that was really a
good addition I had some kimchi radishes
and I just like to squeeze lime on top
of my little lentils and some wilted
cilantro this is so good this is another
delicious vegan meal in the book so
we're getting protein and fiber from the
lentils and more protein and calcium
from the tofu and the vitamin C from the
lime will also help to boost iron
absorption as well it's balanced vegan
friendly and with that little extra dose
of fermented kimchi it's a gut friendly
Choice as well and my partner was also
doing this cleanse so he made these
yummy juices one is a freshly squeezed
noni juice the other is coconut water
and a lot of Ginger and the last one was
just a pineapple juice so normally I'm
pretty weary when it comes to drinking
juices in the name of gut health since
most juices contain high amounts of
fodmaps which can potentially make
digestive symptoms worse but I will say
that this particular combination may
actually have some scientific Merit so
pineapples naturally contain the
digestive enzyme bromelain which
supports digestion by helping to break
down protein into amino acids likewise
Ginger contains the digestive enzyme
zingobane which likewise helps to break
down protein we also know that ginger
has prokinetic properties which helps to
move things along by stimulating stomach
emptying and gut motility and then
there's coconut water which is rich in
electrolytes making it a great option
for folks who experience loose bowels
ultimately though guys any and all
hydration is essential for a healthy
active gut so if you like the flavor of
these juices amazing go for it if not
water is just fine
so I'm probably just going to do one
orange because I am trying to lower the
sugar even natural sugar I've been
trying to have one serving a day I went
raw vegan for a certain period of my
life and having that much sugar even
just more than like two servings of
fruit a day really threw off my gut it
was awful I was bloated for months after
so digestive symptoms are quite common
among folks who are transitioning to a
more plant-based diet and there are two
primary reasons for this or I guess like
three if we're talking like a raw vegan
diet as is the case here number one a
huge leap in fiber consumption so if
you're not used to eating a lot of fiber
then your body is going to have a pretty
tough time breaking down that fiber from
a higher quantity of plant-based foods
which can lead to uncomfortable
digestive symptoms like gas and bloating
this is why we really recommend a
gradual increase in fiber intake while
also making sure to get enough water in
to move things along number two
fodmaps so in short fodmaps are
fermentable sugars contained in a lot of
fruits and vegetables that can be
difficult for some folks to digest and
because vegan diets are naturally higher
in FODMAP containing fruits and veg some
folks may experience digestive symptoms
as a result and three specific to a raw
vegan diet is the raw part cooking
softens some of those tough fibers
making them easier to digest so raw
foods will always be a lot more work for
your gut to break down thorough chewing
is really really important here as is
eating slowly and intentionally but
basically this Triple Threat can be a
major assault on the bowels which is one
of many reasons why I don't recommend a
fully raw diet all that said I don't
think that it's fair to paint all fruits
with the same bloat promoting brush
oranges for example are low FODMAP and
not particularly how high in fiber
either so having more than one orange a
day probably not going to be a big deal
it has been about one month without
processed sugar I've been filming this
video for a while but I have to say I
don't have any intense Cravings so this
kind of checks out as we know that on
average our taste bud turnover rate is
around 8 to 12 days and this explains
why some sugary foods that perhaps you
used to eat regularly May taste a lot
sweeter after not having them for a long
period of time yeah yeah and the scene
can be said for other basic tastes like
salty bitter sour and Umami but again I
want to point out that these are
physical changes not emotional changes
and while sweet Foods May physically
taste different to Hitomi and perhaps
she doesn't need as much of them to feel
satisfied that emotional desire may
still be there and still deserves to be
honored without judgment all that said
despite the questionable and potentially
dangerous cleansing supplements hitomi's
approach to supporting her gut health is
actually quite sound she prioritizes
gut-friendly foods that contain natural
probiotics and Prebiotic fibers her
meals are balanced nutrient-rich and
varied which not only helps to support a
diverse microbiome but also lowers the
risk of common nutrient deficiencies
which we can potentially run into on a
vegan diet on paper it all checks out
nice job team but this is just a
reminder that emotional satisfaction is
just as important as physical
satisfaction when it comes to long-term
diet adherence and that's the other
important Point here like is there
really much point in doing a cleanse for
four weeks for your gut probably not and
it could potentially cause more problems
down the road if it leads to rebound
eating after said cleanse so cheers to
sporadic donut dates colorful veg and
organs that detox our bodies all on
their own and on that note that's all
that I have for you guys today if you
like this video be sure to give it the
thumbs up leave me a comment below on
Whose diet you'd like to see me review
next subscribe to the channel and I'll
see you next time on Abby's kitchen bye
foreign
[Music]